we connected with the owner of the  winning pizzeria in our eight news now  pizza bracket we did start with dozens  of popular spots here in the valley  ultimately came down to dom de marcos  naked city jordanos and lucinos or  lucino excuse me the final four went  through a taste test on our good day las  vegas morning show and of course you  already know that you ranked dom  dimarcos as the best in town well we  caught up with the owners they say it's  because of their loyal customers that  have become like family  that's the taste  you know it's people love it we  we're very passionate about everything  we do here at dom de marcos and  we love food  so we make it like we're making it for  us  and it works out pretty well apparently  customers not only love their pizza they  also rave about their huge tasty lasagna  if you want to check them out yourself  they are at charleston and wallapie